there has been a story going around that
has been pushed by some people on the
left that I need to short-circuit right
now because we're doing damage to
ourselves we are hurting ourselves with
this story I reported to you earlier
this week that Donald Trump said he's
gonna end birthright citizenship or try
to end it with an executive order and
right away I started seeing memes
and tweets saying wait a second Trump's
first three kids are citizens of the
United States because of birthright
citizenship because they were born to a
non citizen parent in the United States
Ivana Trump and they only got
citizenship because they were born here
they received the birthright citizenship
that Donald Trump wants to get rid of
this is just wrong okay Donald Trump
their dad was a citizen they were born
in the United States to a father who is
an American citizen it is true that
their mother Ivana was not a citizen
until 1988 which is after Don junior was
born
it's after Eric Trump was born it's
after Ivanka Trump was born but even if
you repeal birthright citizenship in the
way that Donald Trump wants to do they
would still be citizens and the reason I
bring this up Pat is that the left
weakens its position when it makes bad
arguments or arguments that are
difficult to defend like this one
because as soon as you get debunked the
right will say you can't trust these
people on this issue look at the dumb
argument they made about Trump's own
kids we can't listen to them and
unfortunately the truth is that you can
still make other wise good arguments
even if you wrongly state that the first
three of trumps kids earned birthright
citizenship in this way the reality is
that there are more important
discussions to have like let's go after
whether it's legal for Trump to repeal
birthright citizenship by executive
order that's a relevant discussion let's
go after whether birthright citizenship
is a good thing because of all the other
issues that relate to birthright
citizenship that I explained earlier in
the week there are other hypocritical
image
issues like if you want to personally
point out that Trump's a hypocrite on
this issue you have better ground to
stand on he claims to be against chain
migration Melania Trump spare ins got
citizenship in the United States because
of chain migration he's against people
working illegally in the US yet he hired
people working illegally in the u.s. to
build some of his real estate projects
Melania was in the United States on a
non work visa and she was working and
that's Trump's wife like there are much
more accurate ways to go after Trump's
hypocrisy and Pat I think it is a
mistake to even mention this again and
my advice to the left is don't talk
anymore about Trump's three kids and
then getting birthright citizenship
because it's just a bogus story there
are countless examples of Trump
hypocrisy you don't necessarily have to
bring it up here and it's certainly
nothing that would get weighed out by
the courts who would evaluate whether or
not this is legal if Trump in fact does
try to sign an executive order to end
birthright citizenship but we also
talked this week about how the precedent
argument isn't necessarily the best one
because it's not clear that we've always
had that guaranteed right to birthright
citizenship back since the Fourteenth
Amendment so yeah you have to weigh it
on its merits and I think that's where
liberals should focus and to be very
clear like is the timing of this entire
birthright citizenship thing a
convenient distraction from the fact
that we need to be voting now and
Republicans are scared of losing seats
and possibly control of the house of
course is Trump overall a total
hypocrite on foreigners using American
resources obviously the guy has no
problem with rich Russians using
American law and real estate and
financial institutions to buy condos and
potentially launder the money through
Trump and then they get to have their
kids be citizens because they now own
that condo and are in the US and those
kids are born here of course the guy's a
huge hypocrite but Trump's kids are not
beneficiaries of birthright citizenship
it's a weak argument and even talking
about it weakens the left's position so
please don't fall for it
today's program is sponsored in part by
the mr and ms collection offering our
audience 20% off when you use the coupon
code Pakman at checkout I need this
I can barely figure out how to dress
it's embarrassing to say but the mr. and
Miss collection is your own personal
wardrobe styling service for both men
and women and here's how it works you
tell them about your sizes and
preferences you tell them how you like
to dress what your sort of general style
is and their team of stylists will
handpick clothing items that are styled
just for you and customized to your
needs you get the clothes you can wear
the ensemble they picked out for you you
can mix and match each item with clothes
you already own you can keep any of the
clothes as long as you want but when you
do decide to send things back they'll
send you a whole new set of clothes
selected once again just for you you
even have the option of buying an item
if it's something you really like and
it's all included with one low monthly
fee shipping is always free you get
several pieces of clothing for a price
you would usually pay for one item at a
store great way to evolve your personal
style but you can continually give them
feedback about what you like and don't
like it's especially great for all of
the holiday parties and get-togethers
that are coming up over the next couple
of months a subscription also makes a
great holiday gift for somebody else and
our viewers can get 20% off just click
the link underneath this video select
men or women and use coupon code PA k ma
n at checkout